[Musique]
à l'occasion de la 11e édition des
weekends nature une conférence de presse
a eu lieu à l'espace redley du bas de la
rivière du 10 au 31 octobre 2015 le
département de La Réunion propose de
vivre une expérience de découverte ou de
redécouverte des espaces naturels
sensible réparti sur toute l'île ces
sites abritent un patrimoine naturel
unique au pays somptueux et à la
biodiversité
exceptionnelle sujet au cœur de
l'actualité internationale le Conseil
départemental a décidé pour cette
édition 2015 de sensibiliser le public
sur le changement climatique alors cette
année on a proposé de de partir sur la
thématique climat et nature alors parce
que c'est une année particulière on
parle beaucoup de changement climatique
et on s'est dit que les gens auraient
peut-être envie de savoir exactement ce
que c'était que cette histoire de
changement climatique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en parle avec beaucoup
de grands concepts et et nous on observe
quand même dans les dans dans les
milieux naturels que le le climat ça a
un impact direct et que les plantes les
plantes mais aussi la faune les oiseaux
ont développé une des des des
ingéniosités pour s'adapter au
changement climatique et donc on a
peut-être beaucoup pas à apprendre de la
nature pour la 2e année consécutive les
manifestations seront ouvertes au plus
grand nombre en effet diverses
animations originales et variées seront
accessible aux personnes porteuses de
handicap déjà le département intervient
fortement pour les personnes porteuses
de handicap donc ça nous paraissait euh
au niveau de l'environnement ça nous
paraissait important de pouvoir toucher
tous les publics du département et euh
et puis c'est surtout que euh les
espaces naturels ils sont pour tous les
réunionnés
donc donc on essaie justement même si
c'est pas toujours facile on essaie de
de bah d'ouvrir au maximum les sites que
tout le monde puisse en profiter je vais
prendre un petit exemple parce que c'est
alors il y a des choses qui paraissent
très compliquées donc par exemple pour
les les les personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est toujours compliqué parce que ça
nécessite des aménagements mais après il
y a d'autres actions qu'on peut faire
qui sont plus faciles à mettre en place
par exemple faire de la traduction en
langage dessiges de toutes les
animations donc aujourd'hui c'est
possible toutes les personnes
malentendantes peuvent participer à
toutes les visites qui sont proposées il
y aura un traducteur en langage des
signes comme chaque année la
collectivité offre une véritable
invitation au voyage au travers de plus
de 180 visites guidées
[Musique]
gratuites